you know i am not an expert on the
around thing i would say a few things
about it though that are that interest
me first of all fareed zakaria the
editor of Newsweek and and truly an
expert on international relations has
said we may have to live with a nuclear
Iran we deterred China we deterred the
Soviet Union we can deter around he is
thereby becoming a realist John
mearsheimer says the same thing a leader
of the realist so I I listen to those I
find that interesting I wish their
voices were more included I would also
say that the 67 war between the Arab
nations and Israel was triggered in part
by the fact that Israel was getting
nuclear weapons at that time nuclear
weapons are highly destabilizing and so
now iran is getting it and it's creating
these noam chomsky said on big think
that that whole area should become a
nuclear free zone and that americans
support that and that's what I support
you